the winemaker e-district is now on a restricted fire season this means that notifies and the idea can be left without a permit and the season extends until further notice these restrictions apply to all fires on the beaches and close the lighting of fireworks use of outdoor brazzers and Shimon ears burning rubbish & Drums is also restricted at least the drum is fully enclosed and fitted with the flu charcoal barbecues are considered fires in the open and are restricted however gas barbecues and pizza ovens fitted with flows are fine to use when applying to the waimakariri district council for a permit it can take up to five days to carry a site inspection and process for permanent so apply early once you have a permit any conditions printed on it must be observed make sure you check out the safety tips on the video link below so remember now I've been near fires without permit and as always think before you light [Music]